opération de développement social des
quartiers c'est un plan état région
collectivité il concerne en bretagne six
quartiers de à brest à saint malo et
lorient et deux arènes dont celui de
maurepas le quartier du gros chêne à
mort passe est une dizaine de tour de 15
étages et 91 le mouvement chacune plus
quelques immeubles totalisant 500
appartements
l'ensemble est en action 60 selon les
normes des constructions sociales de
l'époque et pour faire face à la poussée
démographique apparaît aujourd'hui comme
la des sites les plus sensibles de la
ville de rennes il a donc été choisi
comme six autres en bretagne pour
bénéficier de l'opération de
développement social des quartiers lancé
l'an dernier sous forme de contrat de
plan etat-région collectivités locales
en cinq ans 14 cents logements vont être
rénovés les travaux viennent de
commencer
les pièces prioritaires sont les salles
d'eau où sont installés des baignoires
notamment et les cuisines où l'on refait
les éviers et les installations pour
tous appareils ménagers alors par
ailleurs les grosses interventions c'est
les terrasses et puis aussi les
ascenseurs qui vont être remis en duplex
banques qui vont s'arrêter à tous les
étages et qui donc vers ce ne
desserviront beaucoup mieux donc chacun
des étages
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
en attendez de ses travaux une nouvelle
façon d'habiter une embellie ça fait je
suis pas un nouveau confort aussi
surtout parce que vos salles de bains
besoin que lorsque les appartements
seront terminés les locaux communs et
les espaces extérieurs recevront à leur
tour un coup de neuf et pour que cette
amélioration du confort et de
l'environnement atteigne vraiment son
but un accompagnement coordonnées de la
vie du quartier est assurée par les
équipes sociales on s'demande
grâce à l'équipe opérationnelle a
regroupé les efforts des acteurs sociaux
aussi bien dans le domaine de la
formation que dans le domaine de
l'animation de dans le domaine de
l'insertion pour que les familles se
sont bien soutenus
un effort particulier est menée
notamment en faveur de la petite enfance
trois enfants par semaine en moyenne
sont signalés en danger dans ce quartier
un dispositif d'accueil sera donc
développé à l'intention des familles